eux, n'augmentent pas aussi
rapidement. Olivier Bachand.
- Peu importe où l'on va,
peu importe ce que l'on achète,
l'inflation nous rattrappe.iiiii
à la station service.
- En tant que livreur, sûrement,
je pense à changer de travail.
- Je suis serrée pas mal, là...
Mais au Mais au moins je sais gr
mon argent, mais je suis rendue
- T'sais, la classe moyenne?
Il y en a quasiment plus, là.
- Tu dois choisir où tu vas
dépenser ton argent, tu peux pas
- Outre l'essence, des hausses
de prix importantes ont aussi
de la dernière année pour
les véhicules neufs et usagés,
les vêtements, le logement
et les aliments qucerie ou au r.
- À un moment donné, on n'est
plus capables d'arriver, t'sais,
le manger, ces affaires-là,
la comma- L'inflation a atteint%
au pays en juin comparativement
à l'an dernier, un sommet
inégalé depuis 1983.
Pendant ce temps, les salaires
ont progressé de 5,2 %.
leur pouvoir d'achat diminuer.ae
Option consommateur
- Ça touche particulièrement
les personnes qui sont à plus
dont les revenus sont fixés
dans le temps, dns
retraités par exemple qui
ne voient pas leurs prestations
- Certains ménages devront
refaire leur budget.t.t.t.
- Ça peut vouloir dire peut-être
faire des choix qui sont plus
vraiment faire un ordre
de prioroir
quelles sont les dépenses
qui sont prioritaires,
pourrait peut-être retarder.
HAMEL, intervenante,
Ass. coop économie familiale Qc
- On peut penser au cellulaire,s
dans trois sevices de
télécommtélécommtélécommtélécom,
écoutez faut refaire un tour
de piste là dessus, faut se
- Pour calmer la surchauffe, lar
son taux directeur d'un point,
à 2,5 %, la semaiurager
les ménages à épargner plutôt
qu'à dépenser.
BENOÎT DUROCHER, économiste
principal, Mouvemeque du Canquea
est vraiment à l'attaque
par rapport à l'inflation.
- Une politique monétaire
et des tevraient éventuellement
freiner la demande, ce qui
pourrait amener éventuellement
un ralentissement de
- Et les hausses de taux
d'intérêt ne sont pas terminées.
La Banque du Canada estime
qu'elle devra de nouveau
pour endiguer l'inflation.
Ici Olivier Bacha